100 linkedin videos and  personal brand yeah i think when people  enjoy the process and we invest a lot of  time into these candidates that when  they  get a job they are really grateful  especially when they're making that  really important decision they're so  grateful to us that  when they're happy with the process they  do want to send their friends to you  they've just got a really cool job  they're at the pub saying oh i've done  this they are going to send you  referrals so  we were talking about it um on one of  the recruitment mentors sessions of if  you've given someone that good  experience  they are going to want to refer their  friends to you because it's built that  element of trust yeah the recruitment  mentors podcast is proudly sponsored by  vincerie and the award-winning sauce  breaker